and so we need to expand the task of
science to construct a theory that can
accommodate both the data of observation
experiments of course but also this
privately known reality of consciousness
my guest today is Philip Garth Philip is
an associate professor of philosophy at
Durham university in the United Kingdom
with a focus on the nature of
Consciousness but when we're trying to
explain Consciousness it's not about
explaining Behavior with mechanisms it's
about accounting for this invisible but
undeniable privately known reality of
our feelings and experiences he is a
proponent of something called pan
psychism Which is this really
interesting theory that everything
material in our universe has some
element of individual Consciousness
which is a theory that he explores in
his fascinating book called Galileo's
error which I highly recommend it's
Consciousness that's fundamental and the
physical world arises from underlying
facts about mind or Consciousness we
explore pan psychism of course we talk
about the science of mind the nature of
reality and Consciousness as well as the
Multiverse Ai and spirituality I would
argue that actually what we have at
Roots here is a philosophical rather
than a purely scientific problem and I
think until we confront the
philosophical underpinnings of the
problem we're not really going to make
progress towards a solution it was
really utterly fascinating talking to
Philip and this conversation is one that
I must admit began to
stretch just past the boundary of my
intellectual capabilities and I mean
that in the most enjoyable way possible
so from the mystery of my mind to the
mystery of yours please enjoy this
appearance in Consciousness my
conversation with Philip Goff
[Music]
welcome to Los Angeles welcome to the
United States I know that you were just
in London and New York City engaging in
debates on the nature of Consciousness
how did that go yeah it was it was great
fun it was brilliant there was sold out
theaters of this is the General Public
first in London then in New York just
it's incredible actually to see so many
people interested in science and
Consciousness is unbelievable and you
know great questions and you know
hanging out chatting to people
afterwards and yeah it was like it was
really loads of fun it's pretty cool
well I'm delighted to have you here
today this is a long time in the making
I think uh it's been a couple years of
us going back and forth and we were
trying to do this before the pandemic
um and uh it took a while but here we
are we got there in the end exactly
thanks but yeah thank you
um so today the intention is to tackle
the hard problem of Consciousness I
think in order to you know engage in
that discussion we have to Define our
terms a little bit and set the context
and and the terrain before we even
define consciousness though maybe it's
worth explaining why it is a hard
problem like we call it the hard problem
what is the the the kind of Genesis of
of of
characterizing this in that form yeah I
think that is a good place to stop
because
I think so many people in my view
misunderstand the nature of the problem
and I think that is one of the things
that's really
starting to block progress
so I mean the way
this maybe I could start with the way
it's standardly set up it's standardly
characterized as
purely scientific problem
you know that the challenge of
explaining how brains produce
consciousness
you know how electrochemical signaling
is able to
bring about this in a world of colors
and sounds that each of us knows every
second of Waking Life and the thought is
generally oh you know we just need to
plug away with our standard ways of
investigating the brain and we'll crack
it but I would argue that actually what
we have at root here is is a
philosophical
rather than a purely scientific problem
and I think until we
confront that the philosophical
underpinnings of the problem we're not
really going to make progress towards a
solution right and and talk a little bit
about your Evolution to that realization
that the answers that we seek lie in
more of a philosophical exploration than
a materialist uh physics hard science
path yeah well this is an old problem
going back
a few centuries
um it's what's traditionally been known
as the the Mind Body problem
and I think
the problem arises because we have two
very different ways of accessing reality
perception and introspection
so through perception we access the
physical world around us via our senses
and we've learned to do that more
accurately and precisely through science
and through introspection we access
Consciousness via our immediate
awareness of our own feelings and
experiences
so the challenge of the Mind Body
problem then is
how to bring together
these two seemingly very different
things Consciousness and the physical
world into a single unified picture of
reality and broadly speaking there are
there are three options
option one
the materialist option is that the
that's the physical world that's
fundamental that we know through science
and Consciousness somehow arises from
physical processes in the brain
second option the one I prefer
pan psychism turns that on its head
right so it's it's Consciousness that's
fundamental
and the physical world arises from
underlying facts about mind or
consciousness
third option dualism which is the option
that we take both Consciousness and the
physical world
as fundamental but different aspects of
reality so this is this is an old
problem philosophers have wrestled with
for hundreds of years and it's
essentially a philosophical problem
because
all of those three views I've just
described
are empirically equivalent which means
you can't do an experiment to
distinguish between them
so it's not it's it's not in essence
experiments are very important in ways
we could talk about but it's not in
essence a scientific problem so I think
it's almost like we've taken this
ancient philosophical problem
labeled its science and then we find
Science can't answer it it's like maybe
you know like trying to solve a math
problem looking down a microscope or
something we need to understand what
what the what the problem essentially is
wouldn't the materialist contend that we
can solve it with hard science we're
just not at the point where we're
capable of doing it yet
yeah yeah so it's a tempting thought I
mean
and that's well I was just debating in
London a couple of nights ago anal Seth
the neuroscientist really great
neuroscientist
a good friend of mine as well as a
philosophical enemy we you know we've
debated each other a couple of times now
and this is his line you know we've um
he makes the analogy to life
you know we used to think life was this
big mystery maybe we'd never give a
scientific explanation without the
Supernatural vital spark or something
but then we plugged away with the
science and the problem kind of
dissolved and so he thinks the same is
going to happen with consciousness
but I think
that's that's that's not a good analogy
because
life was a purely scientific problem
it was just about accounting for
observable data
what you can observe about the
the living functions of organisms in
other words defining what constitutes
being alive versus inanimate
yeah explaining
what organisms can do what they're made
of how they behave how they function
where they came from that's where
Evolution comes in
but the distinctive thing about
consciousness
is that it's not publicly observable
right I can't
cut open your head and look in your
brain and see your feelings and
experiences we know about Consciousness
not from
experiments it's not something we
discovered in a particle collider we
know about Consciousness in a very
different way just from our immediate
awareness of Our Own
feelings and experiences if you're in
pain you're just
directly aware of your pain
now you know science is used to dealing
with things you can't observe like
fundamental particles or
Quantum wave functions or even other
universes some physicists entertain
but there's a really important
difference in the case of consciousness
in all these other cases
we theorize about things we can't
observe
in order to explain what we can observe
that's the whole task of science
explaining the publicly accessible data
of observation and experiments
but in the case of consciousness
that's not what we're doing in the case
of Consciousness the thing we are trying
to explain
is not publicly observable and that's
why it's it's it's a wholly different
kettle of fish do you have that
expression yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's it's it's it's almost too difficult
to even talk about
because you can't tease out or parse
um Consciousness from
anything else like it is the essence of
being right there is no there is nothing
that is not conscious experience yeah so
you can't create a distance between
yourself and the subject of the
discourse which is consciousness because
you are participating in it right is
that a way I don't know it's like it's a
very strange thing so so before we even
go any further like let's just define
consciousness like how you define it how
you think about it so we know what we're
talking about here
it's it's it's a it's a good place to
start because it is such a slippery word
that people use in all sorts of
different ways
but the way I would Define it Define it
which is which is pretty standard I
think among both philosophers and
scientists
is that your Consciousness is just what
it's like to be you so right now you're
having a visual experience of this room
an auditory experience of my voice
speaking to you
if you pay attention you can notice the
tactile sensations of the chair under
your body this is all
aspects of what it's like to be you
right now right all aspects of your
Consciousness this is the the classic
kind of Nagel definition that's right
legals I find it to be not that
satisfying though like it to me it feels
like
it's similar to the Supreme Court's
definition of pornography like you know
it when you see it it's sort of like
what is it like to be you is what
Consciousness it feels circular like
yeah defining Consciousness as as as
someone who is experiencing
Consciousness yeah well I think you're
right I think it you know it is circular
because I think what we're dealing with
is
essentially A Primitive contact concept
you can't Define it in other ways uh
maybe it's like Louis Armstrong
when asked about allegedly asked what
Jazz was he said if you have to ask
you'll never know but um
for some people that Nagle term works so
Nagel said
in his famous paper what's it like to be
a bat from the 70s he said something's
conscious
if there's something that it's like to
be it so there's something that it's
like for a rabbit to be cold or to be
kicked Stakes are vivid example but we
tend to think there's nothing that it's
like for a table to be cold or to be
kicked or to be sawn enough there's
nothing that's like from the inside as
it were
uh so for some people that works I don't
know how well it translates actually and
some people like yourself think I mean I
find most people just when you say
experience or subjective experience
they kind of get onto it and you know
teaching
philosophy undergraduates
there's a lot of philosophical Concepts
they find it hard to get a grip on
but this one
people tend to people tend to get pretty
easily so
uh there are some people who think there
isn't a real concept here and we're
playing language games and wasting our
time but most people
on both sides of the debate
tend to think there is a notion we can
get onto and work with him right so we
have this materialist notion which is
that the nature of Consciousness is is
is
something that can be deduced through
the scientific method at some point
right then we have
um we have this dualist notion which is
a much more mystical notion which is
that there is the material world that we
can study then there is this world of
Consciousness that lives in a in some
kind of Realm Beyond matter that we
don't quite understand and to which the
scientific method does not apply
both of these are problematic from your
perspective pan psychism is sort of
um the you know the best explanation
from your point of view in a world in
which nothing is quite adequate in terms
of understanding or explaining this this
the nature of what Consciousness is is
that a fair yeah assessment so I think
maybe
dualists contemporary Duelists might
push back a little at the way you
describe the position that I suppose we
do tend to think of it as something kind
of mystical and religious Supernatural
but actually that probably the most
famous contemporary duelist David
Chalmers who was in the audience that's
the New York debate last night
um
I mean I think he's probably the most
secular pro-science atheist guy I've
ever met and um
I once asked him if he was religious and
he said
only in the sense that the universe is
cool but
um he calls himself a naturalistic
dualist
so he thinks um Consciousness is not
physical
it's separate from the brain and the
it's it's separate at least from the
physical processes in the brain
but
he wants to bring it into the scientific
story he wants to expand science to
incorporate this
non-physical element
and so he postulates what he calls
psychophysical laws
these are special laws of nature over
and above the laws of physics which
somehow connect up
the physical world to Consciousness and
he thinks then it's it's then a
scientific question we need to work out
what these laws are we should look to
Neuroscience so he he wants to sort of
expand science
and um
even with materialism saying it's the
scientific option I suppose
I would qualify that a little bit by
saying the materialist tries to explain
Consciousness in terms of physical
science
chemistry physics neuroscience
these kind of things so so so that's the
materialist position that I ultimately
think is inadequate
but science science could be something a
bit more General Science doesn't have to
be tied to
physical science understood as chemistry
neuroscience and so on so I guess all of
us would want to say you know
we're not giving up on science it's just
some of us like David Chalmers from his
perspective
his Jeweler's perspective me from my pan
psychus perspective want to have a
slightly more expansive conception of
what science is and that expansion that
that expansive notion of it would
consider things like
particle physics or or string theory
you know when you sort of think about
what we don't understand about physics
and science we think of things like dark
matter Etc you know like these
mind-blowing kind of Concepts that that
you know me as a non-scientist you know
have a difficult time just understanding
the idea of you know uh you know
alternate realities and parallel all
these sort of things that that quantum
physics contemplates perhaps there is
some explanation or or path to Clarity
that can be gleaned from those
disciplines that we haven't quite
mastered at this point
yeah so it's you know I'm not here to
tell scientists
not to do their job or to do it
differently it's about
having a more expansive conception of
what science is because
the way we the way we currently think
about science
the whole task is
accounting for the data of observation
and experiments that's that's the job
once we've done that if we could have
some Grand unified theory
that accounts for the data of
observation and experiments that's job
done we can Pat ourselves on the back
and go home
but
I want to say that's that's that's not
all that we need to explain because
there's this other thing we know about
this other thing we know to be real
that's not known about free observation
experiments
namely Consciousness something we know
about in a quite different way just
through being immediately aware of it
and so we need to expand the task of
science
and we need to be aiming to fit to
construct a theory that can accommodate
both the data of observation experiments
of course
but also this
private privately known reality of
Consciousness so
I mean in Galileo's era I I frame that
as expanding science these days I guess
I would say more about it's just about
appreciating that we need to do
philosophy as well as science sure we
need to understand that philosophy has a
distinctive and ineliminable role to
play
in um in this project of finding out the
nature of reality that we're all aiming
at and that's both this goes both to the
error that Galileo made from your
estimation but also to the sort of
correctness of his assessment that there
are things that can be physically
measured through scientific tools and
then there are other things that are not
that require a different sort of toolkit
I guess to better understand so explain
why you made this the title of the book
and where that bifurcation you know has
kind of LED science in terms of how we
think about Consciousness perhaps
wrong-headedly
yeah I mean it's a it's a somewhat
provocative title I actually I'm a huge
fan of Galileo it is a clickbaity kind
of thing yeah there was an earlier by uh
Antonio dimasio called called Descartes
era and I guess I'm a bit
a bit sick of everyone bashing Descartes
so I thought I'll
provoke a little by uh
having Galileo's era but um no I think
Galileo in many ways had a much better
understanding of these issues than we do
now
what Galileo essentially wanted to do
was have science
to be purely mathematical
which is something we kind of take for
granted now
but this was a really radical unusual
step for Galileo in 1623 to declare
right from now on
what he called natural philosophy guess
what we now call physical science is
going to be purely mathematical I have
this purely quantitative language
but but I think Galileo appreciated
that you can't capture the qualities of
conscious experience in these terms the
that deep red you experience as you
watch the Setting Sun the smell of
coffee the taste of chocolate you can't
capture these qualities
in the purely quantitative language of
physical science you can't even
articulate them you know
um so Galileo essentially says
well you know if we if we want a
mathematical science if we want a purely
quantitative science
we need to take Consciousness outside of
the domain of science
um so so Galileo's worldview you have
this division between two domains you
have the domain of science
the physical world with its purely
mathematical quantitative properties
and the domain of Consciousness
Consciousness with its qualities colors
sounds smells tastes
um
and that that you know that that's gone
really well
um and I think we're now at a point
where people think
oh it's gone really well it's gone so
well it's gonna explain Consciousness
But the irony is
it's it it's the project of physical
science has gone so well since and
arguably because
Galileo put Consciousness outside of its
domain of inquiry so the fact that
physical science has done incredibly
well
once we take Consciousness out
doesn't really isn't really going to
give us confidence that it's going to be
able to deal with Consciousness itself
that's the uh right and the tricky thing
here you know at the risk of of sounding
like this is gonna take a turn into like
bong head philosophy is that science can
explore to to extend the chocolate
metaphor like science can explain what
chocolate is the chemical composition of
chocolate uh what happens you know to
your nervous system when that chocolate
hits your taste buds Etc but what it can
explain for or account for is the
experience of enjoying chocolate like
that you know that is like a
incalculable
uh thing that exists Beyond language or
uh the ability for the traditional
scientific method to adequately explain
yeah yeah exactly so
don't get me wrong science is crucial
for dealing with Consciousness uh
but
in relation to the Mind Body problem I
think the primary thing science can help
us with
is working out which kinds of brain
activity
go along with which kinds of conscious
experience
uh so you you can't access Consciousness
through perception you can't look inside
someone's head and see their feelings
but you can access brains through
perception and you can
scan people's brains and and you can ask
them if it's a human being
you can ask them what they're feeling as
you scan their brain or maybe look for
external markers of Consciousness and in
this way neuroscientists
try to work out which kinds of
physical activity in the brain go along
with which kinds of conscious experience
or more generally
What What In general what kinds of
physical activity in general are
unnecessary and sufficient for
Consciousness and that's really
important data
but that's not the complete story of
Consciousness what we ultimately want
is an explanation what okay why
why does
certain kinds of brain activity go along
with conscious experience why should
that be and it's it's then that the
philosophy kicks in then we're at the
Mind Body problem because that venue
what you need is a theory of Ultimate
Reality
that explains why Consciousness appears
in the physical world at all and and
that that's where the experiments can't
settle the matter because consciousness
is not a publicly observable datum and
and that's never that's never been what
physical science has been aiming at as I
think Galileo understood yeah and it's
also very difficult it's it's I don't
know if I would call it counterintuitive
but it's very difficult like our
intuition around what Consciousness is
is it doesn't really kind of land at the
bullseye right which makes this
hard to talk about and hard to kind of
even wrap our brains around but
essentially
um
you know what you're saying and please
again correct me if I'm wrong is that
the traditional modality for
understanding Consciousness has more to
do with Consciousness arising out of
matter and the pan cyclist would say
that matter arises out of Consciousness
which is a way of saying that
Consciousness is fundamental to reality
and to matter itself and that it is at
the baseline from which everything the
Gen from which the Genesis of everything
else emerges yeah yeah we have this
essentially philosophical choice that we
have to confront it's not a scientific
choice that you can settle with an
experiment it's a philosophical choice
do we start with Mata do we start with
the physical universe and try and get
Consciousness out
or do we start with consciousness
and try and get the physical Universe
out
or do we start with both that's that's
the Duelist option and
I mean as far as I'm concerned
if we think about the materialist option
of of trying to get Consciousness out of
physical processes in the brain
we find that I that there has been
absolutely no progress on trying to make
sense of that right nobody has ever
managed to
make sense of how you could get
Consciousness out of purely physical
processes in the brain the science has
gone really well you know of of telling
us which kinds of brain activity go
along with conscious experience
but no one's ever come up with an
explanation of how how you could get
Consciousness out of physical brain
activity whereas when you come to
pansychism
I would argue actually we've already
worked out how this can be done the
problem is essentially solved and I
guess we can get on to this but here I
think Bertrand Russell should be seen as
the Darwin of Consciousness in the 1920s
he essentially worked out how we could
account for
physical reality in terms of underlying
facts about mind and Consciousness so
here's our choice
the materialist explanatory project that
no one has ever made any progress on
or the Pan psychist Expansion Project
which is already complete so in my mind
it's kind of a no-brainer right all
right so so much to unpack here but
explain to me how you arrived at this
perspective yourself I mean you're
somebody who by your own admission like
has been obsessed with
Consciousness from a very early age
you've been thinking about this for a
very long time and pan psychism wasn't
your initial you know knee-jerk default
perspective on all of this absolutely
not no so when when I studied
philosophy and the dying members of the
20th century
uh we were just given these two options
no one told me about pan psychism we
were given I didn't I didn't even read
David Chalmers actually as an
undergraduate
in my I had philosophy of mind every
year my degree and I didn't read David
Chalmers
um but anyway we had these choices
are you a materialist
explain it in terms of physical
processes in the brain or are you a
duelist somebody who thinks
Consciousness is outside of the body in
the brain
um and I wanted to defend the materials
option I thought this is the
uh you know this is the scientifically
credible option not like all that
superstitious religious stuff uh which I
now think is
a bit unfair on on the Duelist but
anyway that's how I was thinking as a
Young Man
and you know I defended the materialist
option but I slowly came to think for
some of the reasons we've just been
talking about
that you just can't
explain Consciousness in these terms you
can't account for the the qualities of
experience the redness of a red
experience for example
in the purely quantitative language of
Neuroscience
and so
I thought well I still want to be a
materialist so I decided I was going to
deny the reality of my own my own
conscious experience
this is what's become known as The
Illusionist position uh defended for
example by my uh co-host on my podcast
mind chat Keith Frankish yeah who um
denies the reality of Consciousness
under a certain understanding of that
word at least
um so so I bravely tried to embrace this
you know and defended it and but then I
I think I lasted about three months and
then I just remember just kind of
sitting in a bar I don't know enjoying a
drink and a cigarette you could smoke in
bars in those days and feeling the music
a bit of adrenaline and
just
just couldn't do it anymore just the
reality of having such a is such a
palpable yeah experience it's obvious
yeah it's not an illusion isn't it it's
I it's hard to make sense of what an
illusion would be without Consciousness
and so but after that I I
think I was a sort of closet duelist so
I sort of thought
had problems of dualism but thought that
seems to be the only problem and I
actually wrote my end of degree
dissertation
arguing that the problem is irresolvable
and I just tried to forget about it I
lived in Poland for a bit to try to
right distance yourself from this
obsession with Consciousness read about
science that was yeah so people think
people think I like Mysteries because
I'm depending pod Cycles but I don't I
don't like Mysteries I hate Miss I want
to get rid of mystery and so this was so
you know try to focus on reading about
science that was more tractable and
um but then I just happened across
well actually in another article by
Thomas Nagel I think he was a kind of a
Pioneer here he had an article
tent very tentatively defending pan
psychism in the 70s and it was almost
apologetic he was he was sort of giving
an argument but he was like
of course this is ridiculous but
it has something to the argument but um
and I just read it and I just thought
oh my God that just it just avoids all
the problems the problems of dualism on
the one hand the problems immaterialism
on the other and it just gave me a kind
of deep sense of
intellectual peace you know that I that
there's something that can accommodate
both the scientific truth
but also the undeniable lived reality of
conscious experience
and so that just was transformational
really and and then I just tried to find
probably the only philosophy Department
in the UK then that had a pan psychus
Professor Galen strawson at the
University of reading and so I started
graduate study and
turned out okay yeah it uh
it's something that I find myself
wanting to be true which is not you know
a sort of place of Integrity to you know
kind of look objectively at a situation
and try to understand understand the
nature of it but I can't help it it's
like I just think like the world would
be cooler if if Consciousness is the
fundamental kind of base layer of
everything that exists whether you're
uh whether you you are a you know a a
complex organism like a human being all
the way down to inanimate objects I just
think that that
it colors
everything about how you understand
the nature of reality yeah
yeah no I mean I'm right with you that I
always say
they'll catchphrase of mine
we should ultimately be interested not
in the view we'd like to be true but the
view that's most likely to be true and
and you know in Galileo's era and in the
new book I'm working on now you know I
want the truth you know uh but I was I I
always find when I'm arguing with
somebody who dis or disagree with
I can't deny that there's a bit of me
that wants them to be wrong but there's
also a big a stronger part of me think
wondering are they right I want to know
if they're right I want to know yeah I
really do have a deep thirst for the
truth
well you know we'll never know for sure
but to have our best guess
and so
so yeah in Galileo's era and the book
I'm currently working on you know most
of it is just the cold-blooded case the
evidence the arguments
but then we do also want to think about
the implications for human existence so
I tend to have a final chapter you know
yeah what what does this mean to live
this out and I you know so the great
thing about pad psychism is I think
we've got good reason to think it's
probably true but also I think it's
it's slightly better for our mental and
physical health I think because it you
know this isn't this isn't just an
abstract intellectual puzzle
Consciousness is at the root of human
identity
it's this arguably the source of
everything that matters you know from
Deep Emotions
subtle thoughts beautiful sensory
experiences
um
and yeah I'm inclined to think our
official scientific worldview
materialism
is actually just inconsistent with the
reality of consciousness
if it was true there wouldn't be
Consciousness if if all there was was
the purely quantitative story of
physical science
there wouldn't be qualitative experience
and so if if I'm right about that which
is of course a little bit controversial
then we're at a very odd period of
History
were our official scientific world view
denies the existence of
the thing that's most evident and the
thing that Gives Life Meaning and you
know in a way that's wackier than any
religious it's the craziest thing ever
like when you think of it right you
think of your craziest religious
Doctrine I don't know Heaven Hell
whatever
I think we'll look back in history to
this time when people had this world
view that denied their own conscious
feelings and experiences and I think
what the how did they get in that
mindset and I I think I think it's
something to do with being blown away by
the success of physical science and the
incredible technology which is
you know which is incredible which is
rightly celebrated but
it leads us to think this is the truth
we've found the way of getting to the
truth
but I think again the irony is physical
science has been so successful
precisely because it's it's focused on
something quite specific you know
roughly understanding How Stuff behaves
and once you understand how Stuff
behaves you can create technology right
you can manipulate the world
but when we're trying to explain
consciousness
that's not what we're trying to do it's
not about explaining Behavior with
mechanisms it's about accounting for
this
invisible but undeniable privately known
reality of our feelings and experiences
right this Cornerstone idea that we when
it comes to
hard science
we understand
matter through the lens of how matter
behaves yeah but that doesn't account
for what matter actually is yeah so the
thesis is that matter is composed of the
the base elements of Consciousness
somehow somewhere yeah and that this is
this is this is like at the you know at
the basement floor of everything that is
real it is infused with Consciousness
whether it's a rock or whether it's a
human being and that conscious
experience is something
that is binary something is either
conscious or it isn't but the complexity
of that conscious experience toggles up
with the complexity of the organism yeah
is that is that a fair yeah
um I mean just
I don't think pan psychists necessarily
have to think that
literally everything is conscious I
think
I watched a chat with our friend Annika
Harris and I think her person upon
psychism
would think that um
literally everything is conscious I know
she's a bit agnostic on whether it's
true
um I mean her book was my introduction
to this notion we talked about it
briefly in that podcast but that's what
led you know that's what led to this
conversation obviously yeah it's it's
been great that she's managed to really
done a lot to get the idea out there
um but I don't think pansycus
necessarily have to think that as you
say the basic commitment
is that the fundamental building blocks
of reality
have some kind of very very rudimentary
conscious experience maybe fundamental
particles
or maybe universe-wide fields
many theoretical physicists
inclined to think that reality is made
up of fields rather than particles
but just sticking to particles for the
sake of simplicity
just because the particles are conscious
it doesn't mean that every random
arrangement of particles
has Consciousness in its own right so it
doesn't mean your socks or rocks or
tables and chairs are conscious it just
means that the smallest
building blocks they're made up of have
Consciousness so I'd be more inclined to
think
the conditions under which
conscious particles combine to form a a
conscious system that is conscious in
its own right
are comparatively rare
and natural selection
as it were discovered this and exploited
it so probably the the natural world is
filled with Consciousness but
more generally
in the universe more generally it's
probably confined to the level of
fundamental physics but you know this is
an open empirical question we need to
look to Neuroscience to try and pin down
and make systematic
where we get Consciousness at the macro
level of reality so do you think that
Neuroscience is capable of doing that
I hope so I hope so it's it's it is hard
because Consciousness is not publicly
observable
um you know the neuroscientist
Christoph [__]
um bet David Chalmers 25 years ago that
it would all be wrapped up by now you
bet him a crate of fine wine
but I think it's it's time to pay up
because there are you know at least four
or five different theories we're just
talking the neuroscientific theories
and um
there's really no consensus but
I don't know I still have hope that we
can
work with the human case and and
organisms similar to ourselves and try
and work out some kind of
systematic theory of of what kind of
systems do and don't have Consciousness
I still have hope in that project yeah
but it's it's not easy at all yeah
thing that
you know first of all we're even having
this conversation like what you're
proposing is is quite radical uh it it's
still I don't know if it's on the
fringes of how we're thinking about
Consciousness
um but if it is less so than it used to
be by Dent of your book and Annika and
other people who are you know thinking
about this a little bit more deeply than
we have in the past and I think we're at
an interesting kind of juncture in terms
of how we're grappling with the nature
of Consciousness but I would say I'm
interested in from your perspective you
know most people are probably still
quite dismissive of what you have to say
and just straw man your argument would
be to say that there is no scientific or
objective evidence to support any of
your thesis I agree with you I agree
with you I'm
I don't think you can scientifically
prove the particles have Consciousness
because Consciousness is not publicly
observable you can't hard problem you
can't look inside an electron to see if
it's conscious just as I can't look
inside your brain to see if your
Consciousness so this is I mean
this is why what how more and more what
I try to press is just getting people to
see look
this this isn't just a scientific issue
there's a philosophical puzzle here that
we have to address as a philosophical
puzzle
and that that puzzle arises because this
put the puzzle would not arise
if the only way we knew about reality
was through experiments then we'd just
do science and some philosophers like
Daniel Dennett seem to think that is or
or we know about reality you know we
just just through experiments but I
think most people think
now there's another way we know about
reality we know about Consciousness
through our immediate awareness now as
soon as you accept that
then you've got this philosophical
challenge how do we bring these things
together
what we know through our senses the
physical world what we know through
directly our direct awareness of our
Consciousness how do we bring them all
together now that's not a scientific
question you can answer with an
experiment it's a philosophical question
so more and more
for you know
before we get on to pansychism I just
want to
try and persuade people of
that essentially philosophical Challenge
and the only way you can avoid it is the
way Daniel Dennett does Daniel denner is
incredibly consistent
he wants to think the only thing we the
only things we know about reality are
through experiments
he knows I think that we don't know
about our first person conscious
experience in that way
so he denies his existence
my good friend Keith Frankish does the
same so that's one option
Daniel Daniel dennett's consistent I
think I'm consistent but I think most
people are sort of in this confused
Middle Ground where they of course
accept the existence of consciousness
but then they don't follow the
implication of that
that
there's something we know about reality
that's not from experiments right and so
we need to engage with a bit of
philosophy
um
you know if if you just zealously follow
this line that no
the only the only way we know anything
is through experiments then
Consciousness is out the window so you
can't have your cake and eat it you've
gotta sure you know it's it's the it's
the philosophical zombie problem right
and I I feel like this
this field of consciousness
is gaining in kind of mainstream
popularity because we're all paying
attention to the Advent of of artificial
intelligence we're watching as AI starts
to come online and we're all grappling
with that Rubicon at which point it
becomes quote unquote conscious as we
understand it so we've seen these
experiments where
um
uh computer scientists are engaging in
dialogue with these AIS and they seem to
be mimicking human behavior almost
perfectly at times so is that
Consciousness I think we would all agree
at this phase it probably isn't it is a
it is a sort of philosophical
zombie situation but at what point does
it become conscious and to take your
your your perspective on pan psychism in
that everything on some level is is is
rooted in some form of Consciousness uh
it's not a stretch to then say that that
that AI has some form of Consciousness
it may not be the kind of Consciousness
that we think about or that we
experience but there is consciousness
baked into that and at some point that
Consciousness will mature to be in
distinct indistinguishable from how we
think of our own lived experience
yeah which is a really tricky
fascinating and all you know also kind
of terrifying thing to think about
yeah I mean you quite read this this
again another reason this isn't just a
an intellectual game they're all very
real world implications
whether AI is conscious does that does
that mean we have to have things start
to think about the ethics of of
artificial systems which animals are
conscious forget you know forget
computers which animals are conscious
and
what does that imply about our our moral
responsibilities
um
are plants conscious
people with arnica talks about that in
her book the whole thing with the fungal
networks and
surgeries but
but actually I don't think pan psychism
necessarily
settles any of these issues I
because as I say as a pancake you don't
have to think
every arrangement of conscious particles
forms a system that's conscious in its
own right so for that question actually
I would just look to the look to the
Neuroscience I'm I'm quite partial to
the integrated information theory of
consciousness
and if that turns out being right if
that turns out to be right then um
actually computers of anything like
the kind we have at the moment are not
conscious and will not be conscious
because
I mean the way the way computers work
you
in contrast to the brain the brain
stores information in a way that's
highly dependent on on connections and
integration and that's the mark of
Consciousness for the integrated
information Theory
but the way we the way a computer's set
up that's not the case it's you can
remove a few transistors you don't take
away too much information so
so actually I think you know we can
distinguish these philosophical and
scientific questions and um
um I might give the same answers as a
materialist or a dualist so you
there needs to be a marriage here
between science and philosophy but um
yeah can I just come back to maybe just
pinning down like why we should believe
this yeah so just please I think the
core of it is as you say of course
it's not it's not about scientific proof
it's not about proof you can't
scientifically prove that electrons are
conscious
what what is attractive here is
the Beautiful
form of explanation that Bertrand
Russell came up with
in the in in the 1920s
uh that was you know forgotten about for
so long but as has recently been
rediscovered and that's why there's so
much Buzz about pansychism surprisingly
in in anglophone philosophy so I think
what what Russell was
doing in the 1920s was thinking really
hard about the fact that our fundamental
science is purely mathematical
this due to Galileo again
and you know that's really useful if
you're a working scientist you can have
really precise predictions but what does
it mean as a philosopher
interested in the ultimate nature of
reality that our our most fundamental
science is pure math
and um
and what Russell realizes is what it
means is
science isn't really telling us that
much about
fundamental reality it's merely
describing it in terms of its abstract
how it behaves how it behaves exactly
it's abstract mathematical structure so
so really
Ultimate Reality could be anything as
long as it it does it has the right
Behavior has the right mathematical
structure
so the way this leads into pansychism so
the pan psychist story is
what's at the fundamental level
uh
networks of incredibly simple
conscious entities behaving in very
simple predictable ways because they
have very simple Consciousness through
their interactions
realizing certain mathematical
structures and patterns
and then the thought is
those mathematical structures and
patterns are what we call physics
so we get physics out of underlying
facts about Consciousness absolutely
beautiful so just to sum it up you can't
get you can't get comfortable mind [__]
all right you can't get Consciousness
out of physical out of physical matter
but you can get physical matter out of
Consciousness we know it can be done so
that is why this is such an attractive
theoretical story you know to my mind it
just solves the problem
and and that's that's the case for
believing it
so there's believing it and
understanding it from a theoretical
point of view do you think that that the
human animal is capable of understanding
it Beyond Theory to really truly
understand it or is that something that
eludes our capacity and our limited you
know faculties
it might not be possible
to fill in all the gaps I was talking to
um Rebecca Goldstein last night who's uh
was it was in this debate in New York
last night who
who said it in on the stage in her youth
she was sympathetic to pan psychism and
um
but she now thinks you know
there's gonna be there's gonna be
there's so much we could never know for
example what is it like to be an
electron okay so say say we accept that
something that's like to be an electron
what is it like to be an electron I mean
as Nagel pointed out we don't even know
what it's like to be a bat
are we ever gonna be able to and and
then
think about our own experience that so
many different kinds of qualities all
the different colors and the difference
between color and sound and
proprioception you know that's your
awareness of where your bodily parts are
all of these
these qualities that seem to have
nothing to do with each other you know
you seem like what what does color have
to do with sound there seems such
radically different kinds of quality
are we ever going to be able to have
some theory that
can predict the very precise quality of
Human Experience from the kind of
consciousness of the level of particles
that it emerges from can we will we ever
do that I don't know maybe maybe not
maybe we won't be able to fill in all
the details just because
to understand something's Consciousness
you have to be able to adopt its
perspective you have to be able to as it
were look out of its eyes we can't adopt
the perspective of
a creature that Echo locates its way
around
so maybe we won't be able to fill in all
the details but actually I think I think
that
in very broad terms
that explanatory story Russell tells I
think is pretty explicable actually I
think it makes perfect sense and so I
make the analogy to Natural Selection
right there's the the basic genius
insight
Darwin had
or Wallace rather you know there was the
other guy Wallace who had it at the same
time and I always feel a bit sorry for
him anyway
that genius idea of evolution by natural
selection that just ex made so
intelligible how you could get
complex organisms emerging without
design
and then you know you have to fill in
the details and it takes a century to
get to DNA that's why I think you know
the story Russell told about how you can
get the physical universe
out of more fundamental facts about
Consciousness you can do it because
physics is purely mathematical so as
long as the Consciousness stuff
gives you the right mathematical
structures you've got physics I think
that makes perfect sense and that was
you know the Eureka moment to me reading
about this stuff but
whether the way we filled out the
darwinian project and continued to do so
whether we can ever do that with
something like Consciousness that's not
publicly observable I don't know but we
can yeah we can have a good go
[Music]
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table and volume 2
follows in that tradition by showcasing
even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with
interview excerpts essays and stunning
photography making for an Exquisite
companion to the first volume or a
satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with this
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
to your point about
forget about you know trying to
understand what it's like to to have the
experience of being a bat let alone an
electron I think that our instincts
around our own conscious experience are
not great right like we know that we're
having a conscious experience but I
don't feel like we're very astute in
understanding the parameters of what
that is right and so for example if
you're to do Sam Harris's uh meditations
and waking up a lot of the prompts in
his meditations are around
um trying to qualify that for you
trying to get you to understand that
you're not being made aware of
Consciousness but that you are aware as
Consciousness that everything that you
are experienced from the pro pro what is
it proper perception yeah to you know
every thought that occurs to you the the
you know extent of your visual field
what you're hearing they are they are
everything is but an appearance in
Consciousness right and to kind of
um break that
illusion of the Observer of your
conscious experience like I had always
thought of it as like my I know my mind
is running a loop and I can have
distance between
what I would call my higher
Consciousness and and like the
ruminations of my you know running mind
to say oh it's interesting that I'm
feeling that way or I keep thinking this
I should stop doing that that there
seems to be a a dualistic kind of like
relationship there
Sam would say no this is an illusion it
is all just appearances in this field of
Consciousness that is everything so much
so that you can't even find the locus of
it like we have this Instinct that it
lives in our head right like our who we
are our identity is this thing behind
our face
all my instincts tell me that that's
true and you know Sam's position would
be to disabuse you of that notion to get
you to understand that that is just part
of
the conscious experience but it is not
rooted in
true reality
yeah yeah so I mean this is
again what an unusual
phenomenon this is that to understand it
you can't go and
look down a microscope to understand
that you've gotta
turn your attention on yourself
and as you say part of that is breaking
through our preconceived ideas about
our own Consciousness even ways in which
we can even get our own our own
Consciousness wrong I mean a lot of
evidence comes out of that from
Neuroscience but also through meditation
having a a deeper understanding of
of what's going on there
um
yeah I I
I'm sort of I guess more agnostic on
on the self than that then Sam and
Annika are maybe I need to meditate a
bit more but
I mean what one thing that makes me
hesitate is I do think there is
a deep Unity to conscious experience so
if you right now I'm having a multitude
of different experiences colors and
sounds and tactile Sensations
but they're not just existing in
isolation from each other
they exist as aspects of a single
unified field of experience if you like
so there's something
unifying the diversity there
and I think that's traditionally some
philosophers have plugged the the self
in there the eye there is the thing
maybe it's very different to how we
ordinarily think about it but there's
something there which is
parceling off which is um bringing Unity
to the diversity
um which we might call the self and I
mean it's a further question does this
thing
persist for long periods of time might
my PhD Mentor Galen strawson has a book
selves where he defends the idea that
there are
unified selves but they just last a
couple of seconds they so there's these
sort of chains of little unified cells
that pop up and disappear and
or another alternative that some people
have defended is that um
the unified self lasts as long as a
period of waking consciousness
but when you have dreamed of sleep or um
general anesthetic you
that self ceases to be and a
another one pops up when you wake up yes
I I recently had a small operation with
general anesthetic and I was kind of
terrified thinking who's gonna wake up
is it gonna be some different
person with with all my memories but
um so I
I'm I'm very agnostic on all this stuff
I'm not as uh
Sam and Annika seem seem pretty
confident maybe I just never meditation
well I mean that goes in yeah the nature
of self and identity and then of course
you know the implications uh for for
free will and choice that that come with
that I mean I think it's pretty
fascinating to to
assume
the pan psychic perspective begs
questions of self and identity right if
Consciousness is the base layer to
everything and it pervades everything
um
you know what are the what are the
implications for identity you know this
sense that
we're always evolving we're always
changing that that that Consciousness is
is this on some level like independent
of who we are in this sense of
personhood and as we grow older and we
look different when we look in the
mirror there is this you know uniformity
that we are the same person and have
always been the same person even if we
undergo surgery or go to sleep at night
yep we wake up and we have those
memories and you know there is a uh you
know an unbroken kind of chain of
essential experience that we consider to
be part and parcel of Who We Are
and so does pan psychism upend that or
change how we think about
identity in that regard
possibly depends it depends what what
direction you take it and I think so
I guess there are
connections between pan psychism and
certain forms of Buddhist thinking or
the advice of adanta tradition in um
Hindu mysticism
um
my friend the Australian philosopher
Muriel Bahari
defends a sort of advice of a danta
inspired sort of mystical philosophy
rooted in that tradition and it's just
interesting because she defends it
with the tools of our philosophical
tradition and analytic philosophy and
this sort of dry rigorous cold-blooded
way
and but yeah she's defending this kind
of um
mystical philosophy on the basis that
she thinks we sh we should take the
testimony of expert meditators as
as a sort of expert just be like you
know I don't I I believe the universe is
14 billion years old is it 14 13
something like that I don't know all the
science but I trust the experts so she
thinks we should think the same about
expert meditators but um
that's one I mean that and you know but
on the other hand
um
another great pan psychus philosopher
who was in the audience at this debate
in New York last night Luke roloffs hmm
who is a pan psychist because he wants
to explain consciousness
buddy has no
mystical or
um any kind of
spiritual Tendencies insofar as that
takes you beyond the regular scientific
picture that's no fun and so uh he's
lacking the fun part he's a lovely guy
he's a fun guy
um but um
so I don't so the way I normally tend to
say is you know it's there's no
necessary connection between pan psyches
and everything spiritual but
um maybe pan psychism is more consonant
with those sort of spiritual views so
you you know if you
if you're a materialist it's hard to
take mystical experiences seriously as
revealing to you something about
Ultimate Reality because Ultimate
Reality of the material says what you
get from physics yeah and it doesn't
seem physics physicists aren't telling
us about this unconditioned
consciousness of the root of things but
if you or if you're a pansychist and you
already think there's
fundamental Consciousness at the base
there then you know it's not too much of
a leap to move to those views I don't
know again
I'm agnostic you know in the case of
pancake is not Russell's story to I
really find that persuasive but here if
Mary or Annika tell him you know trust
meditators that I mean there are
different meditators in different
Traditions there does seem to be in each
tradition
something about in some sense
transcending the self and some deep
Oneness but different Traditions
interpret that in different ways you
know the Buddhists say the self doesn't
exist
the Hindus say um it's it does exist but
it's identical with the sort of divine
mind or something
the abrahamic Traditions think it's
about understanding our Unity with
with the Divine and so
so I don't know I think maybe there's
something there that's
interpreted in different ways in
different Traditions so I'm not so
confident that the the self doesn't
exist as yet not that I'm sort of
attached to it what I think is what is
what it brings up for me is this idea of
of connectivity like if if Consciousness
pervades everything and we don't live in
a vacuum and there are you know billions
of atoms separating us as we talk today
on some level we're connected and
there's a Consciousness that that is
part of that connectivity right and when
you think of it from that perspective
you can't help but think of the nature
of of a unified Consciousness or almost
like
it brings the brings up the question of
like a hive mind Consciousness like if
you're I'm sure when you
flew here from New York and you were you
know descending over Los Angeles and
you're looking down at the urban sprawl
and the cars and all of that it does
look like you know either like the the
semiconductors of a computer or the you
know the veins and arteries and and
organs of some kind of super organism in
which human beings are participating and
and Performing some sort of function
without their conscious awareness
because we're all sort of operating
under some broader Consciousness that
isn't part of our conscious awareness
but his Consciousness nonetheless that's
driving our behaviors and our decisions
in some kind of macro way in the same
way that ants construct an ant hill or
Birds you know know how to flock
together to they're not making conscious
decisions they're just operating under
some kind of instinctual
impulse that perhaps has something to do
with the Consciousness that pervades
everything yeah I don't know that makes
any sense at all but like to like
entertain that as a thought experiment I
think is interesting I think there's
definitely infant psychism there's
there's a picture of the universe we we
fit into much more you know where
conscious creatures in a conscious
Universe it's it's a universe somehow
welcomes us more and
and certainly
going a bit further than that
does seem to be something consistent you
know you give people psilocybin they
they talk about some deep connectedness
some deep Oneness
um they talk about
some living presence pervading all
things
and I take that very seriously and some
people might say well maybe that's just
your brain doing funny things
but I I always come back to the um you
know to that challenge I always come
back to
the response of William James in his
great book in the 19th century the
varieties of religious experience
um
when you say
well why should why should the Mystic
trust their experience
trust that it's telling them something
about Ultimate Reality
he says well
you can't know but it's it's the same
with ordinary sensory experiences right
I've got this experience at this table
here I can't get outside of my
Consciousness and check
uh you just trust that you're
ordinary sensory experiences are
connecting you with reality so so um not
Russell in this case William James says
if you say it's it's okay for
Ordinary People to trust their um
sensory experiences but it's not okay
for a Mystic to trust their Mystic
experience this is sort of double
standard there right I think all
knowledge is rooted in just the decision
to trust experience and
what does it mean to trust experience
right if if everything is an appearance
in Consciousness and when we put our
hand on this table we feel it we know
our hand is here but actually that
sensation isn't occurring in the hand
it's occurring in the brain in the same
way pain isn't you know if I cut my
finger the pain isn't happening in the
finger it's happening in the brain and
if that's just an appearance in
Consciousness it's not a leap it's not
that much of a leap to then Wonder are
we you know in this simulation
experience is this some kind of Matrix
in which we just have a very uh highly
developed and accurate simulation for
creating Sensations that appear to be
real as emergent you know experiences in
Consciousness does pan psychism you know
account for those threads like how do
you think about about the notion that
perhaps we're in The Matrix or that
we're all you know operating in
accordance with some kind of hive mind
Consciousness that's driving us towards
the innovation of an artificial
intelligence that will ultimately
supplant us
wow scary stuff
[Music]
um I mean maybe this comes to maybe the
difference between me and Donald Hoffman
for example
um you know there's certainly something
very close about these views that they
have Consciousness at the base and
everything else flows from that
but
Donald has this idea I guess that
in some sense the physical world doesn't
really exist
uh it's just
tools on our interface
um icons on our interface rather
and
I don't really feel feel the need to go
that far I'm not seeing
the compelling reason to go that far
rather than just saying the physical
world is very different to what we
thought hey it turns out it's made up of
Consciousness but I don't see why that's
just a surprising theory about the
nature of physical reality doesn't mean
we have to say
physical reality doesn't really exist so
maybe this this I mean there's there's
another view on the table here idealism
which I think Donald Hoffman I don't
think he calls himself an idealist but I
think it would fit into that camp that
in some sense the physical world is an
illusion or it's not fully real or it's
it's it's
undergirded by more fundamental facts
about mind and Consciousness whereas the
pansakis tends to say no the fiscal
world is real it's really out there it's
just made up of Consciousness so
maybe these are just two slightly
different takes on the same idea but
yeah no I get it I mean I think
another cool
aspect of contemplating pan psychism
is this
sense of unity like if everything is
consciousness
that helps us to really grok that we're
all in this together yeah right so
whether
you know when we're facing these
existential threats to the you know
health of the planet and the future of
humanity climate change Etc
um
it does put you in a more
compassionate you know mindset of
cooperation right like yeah there is an
inner connectivity between everything we
are interdependent and linked in ways
that you know perhaps we haven't fully
contemplated previously yeah yeah no I
mean I in my book Galileo's era do you
kind of speculate about what it'd be
like to be a child
raised as a as a pan psychist you know
and raised to see
the movement of a plant is in some way
expressing its desires its inclinations
and
um because I mean our our official
scientific worldview tells us that a
tree is just a mechanism
and it's sort of ridiculous to hook a
mechanism it's sort of what you know
that's why we think of tree hooking is
kind of idiotic or some people do
and if you're thinking of a tree as a
mechanism then it's
it has no moral significance in its own
right it's just important because of
looking nice or what it can do for us
whereas if you think of a tree as a a
conscious organism in its own right
then the tree has a moral status in its
own right and
you know see these terrible
burning of forests
in Brazil of of late hopefully changing
now
um you know if you see that as the
burning of conscious organisms it really
it really fires up your Environmental
[Music]
um
desires to make to make to solve the
environmental problem even more
significant
um but yeah I've managed to persuade my
kid I was trying to ask my kids if they
think um
trees are conscious and my daughter said
no they're outside so the so I don't
know what you could only you can only be
conscious if you're indoors well
actually my daughter said some greatest
to me that my five-year-old we were on
the bus
and I said actually Annika and Sam
wouldn't like the sentiments here but we
were on the bus I said do you think the
bus is conscious and she said now it's
just a machine
and I said well on your machine
and she said no I've got I'm a person
which means I don't have things inside
me that make me move I thought that was
I don't know it says real kind of uh
does that Free Will Free Will
um yeah sense there wasn't the that it's
you know there's not I'm not a mechanism
against but yeah anyway
do with what that what you will yeah I
do love the idea of of you know really
understanding the conscious uh you know
aspects of ecosystems we think of a tree
as a tree it's an independent entity but
then to really understand it is to know
that there are you know this this
complexity of underground root systems
that interact with
um mycelium and the communication that
exists between trees among trees that
um you know that that partition so much
as to like take care of progeny of trees
like understanding oh this is this tree
came from me so we're gonna and the way
they share resources Etc like it's the
more you learn about that the easier it
is
to take that leap of of philosophical
Faith yes into this realm and it is like
again like calling myself out like I
want it to be true because I just think
it's beautiful and it allows me to
inhabit a space of awe and wonder that I
think it's just a you know a better way
of living quite frankly
um
so uh yeah I mean on the chase there I
do I do try and encourage my kids to
think about which is just science now
it's not nothing to do about psychism
that the the so-called wood Wide Web the
interconnections of trees under the
ground sharing across species you know
human beings struggle to cooperate
between ethnicity sometimes you know
these trees are helping each other out
across an example so that we should yeah
exactly there is a buzzing blooming
buzzing
let me start that again there is a
buzzing blooming Community underneath
our grounds as we're walking through the
forest we just we're just seeing these
things that stick out of the ground but
you know you you keep coming back which
to um
you want to believe it
um but I think you know sometimes we
we don't always have to think you know
is this true or is this not true
is this true or is it [__] you can
you can engage with something can't you
you can engage with a possibility as a
possibility you can um work with a
possibility
you know I think some if you're thinking
about spiritual experiences
or experience of the Transcendent or
something I think people are people
think either either you think they're
real or you think it's just [__]
something your brain something going
wrong with your brain but there's a
middle way option of engaging these
kinds of experiences and working with
them in a spiritual practice or whatever
without
definitely decide and I mean who the
hell knows what's going on you know you
can you can engage with experiences
whilst remaining agnostic about so here
you are taking this middle path again
right I always I hate the dichotomies
you know it's always the diagonalities
like
are you a U.S capitalist or a Soviet
communist you know are you a materialist
get along let's merge these worlds
because yeah it is it is natural to go
from where we just were into this into
this realm of spirituality religion what
is God like when you think of of of
Consciousness pervading everything is
that not God or could you not perceive
that as you know some definition of uh
you know of of God in that in perhaps a
secular sense
Spinoza's God I guess yeah yeah so if
so we've been talking about pan psychism
as
the little particles being conscious
but as we've also said
theoretical physicists
tend to prefer the idea that
it's universe-wide fields that are the
fundamental building blocks and
particles are just kind of local
excitations in fields
if you combine that view with pan
psychism then it's the it's the
universe-wide fields that are
the fundamental forms of consciousness
and hence
the fundamental conscious entity if
there is one is is the bearer of those
fields I.E the universe itself and I
actually I actually think that's a
that's a more attractive philosophical
conception upon psychism as well
sometimes called Cosmo psychism you know
that the universe is the fundamental
conscious entity
um so there's a macro field of
energy that enervates the subatomic
particles that comprise the nature of
Consciousness is that what you're saying
yeah so the fundamental thing is this
universe-wide mind and
everything else I just
aspects of that universe-wide
Consciousness I actually defended
something like this in my academic book
so I first wrote an academic book
consciousness and fundamental reality
which is probably a bit impossible to
make sense of if you
I haven't done some graduate philosophy
study but that was the direction I I
took that in in my academic book and so
yeah but then is that
it's a further question do we want to
call that God I mean
you might just think I mean we could use
a different word God is a problematic
word it's just you know fraught so we
use a different word yeah
yeah you might just think it's the
country even if the universe is
conscious
maybe it's experience is just a
meaningless mess it doesn't mean it's it
doesn't mean it's got intelligence or
goal directedness
um you know our Consciousness is the
result of millions of years of evolution
but it could be that the universe is
conscious but it's just kind of this
messy meaningless Consciousness although
I have also explored
if you start from that cosmositis
position
and bring in other kind of data like the
fine-tuning of physics that might push
you towards
something more like a goal directed
conscious entity rather than just a sort
of meaningless mess so so again you know
pan psychism
doesn't entail anything spiritual or
anything in that direction but it it can
lead you there if you bring in other
considerations I think and what is what
is your relationship personally with the
spiritual and the mystical and all of
this
laughs
yeah well this is I guess the the new
book I'm working on I just last week
signed a contract with Oxford University
press
um so my first book was an academic book
my second book was aimed at General
audience
so I want this to be both
so it's with an academic publisher but
they're going to Market it as a as a
trade book and and each chapter has a
more accessible bit and then a digging
deeper bit to try and take you into the
more technicalities
but what I'm what I'm exploring is
the middle way between the Middle Ground
between
God and Atheism that's that's the pitch
really it's you know again again it's
all these dichotomies you know it's like
whose team are you on Richard Dawkins or
the pope you know I don't find like when
you're talking to people
it's like they're trying to they're
trying to work out which side you're on
and
and I just as
as the K as in the case of materialism
and dualism I just came to find actually
both the classical
theistic religious position and the
classic the classical kind of atheist
meaningless Universe position are pretty
implausible for different reasons I
think there's things
the traditional atheist picture can't
explain there's things the traditional
religious picture can't explain and
there's just a a huge range of
underexplored positions in between
so so that's where I'm currently engaged
at the moment and trying to match and so
what does that look like specifically
though like how would you characterize
that for for yourself not atheist but
not you know not the pope or whatever
maybe it's not a a you know a
perspective that that is dogmatic in a
religious sense but perhaps strains of
of spirituality pervade this like what
does that specifically mean like what
does that look like so one thing that
that motivates me here is the discovery
of recent decades that
physics the laws of physics seem to be
fine-tuned for the possibility of life
in the sense that
for life to be possible
certain numbers in physics had to fall
in an incredibly narrow range such that
it looks it looks incredibly improbable
that
just by chance our universe would would
have ended up just by chance with the
right numbers for life so I think the
example it seems to
puzzle physicist the most is the um
the cosmological constant
so this was um you know we discovered in
the 1990s that the universe is actually
accelerating in its expansion
and um so that there is postulated a
kind of repulsive
Force which we refer to as dark energy
and and and and the strength of this
force is measured by the cosmological
constant
and what you hear high profile physics
is saying is it's just
what that number turned out to be
was incredibly surprising because it's
it's it's it's not zero but it's a
really really tiny number it's like I
can't remember the exact number now but
it's like Point 38 zeros one three eight
or something it's like tiny number
um
but it's not zero and you know it
physicists like Brian Green's thing you
just you don't find these kinds of
numbers in physics and
um it didn't seem to fit with
of other things we know about physics
but it's fortunate we did have a num
that kind of number because if it was
if it was a little bit bigger
so if this repulsive force was a was a
bit stronger
everything would have shot apart too
quickly for
gravity to Clump things together into
stars planets we wouldn't have had any
kind of structural complexity whereas if
it had been less than zero then it would
have been a an attractive Force rather
than a repulsive force it would have
added to gravity rather than countering
it and everything would have collapsed
in on itself within a split second of
the start of the universe so
so to have any kind of structural
complexity or and life that number had
to be in this incredibly narrow range so
that's like the guard number right like
that's yeah you're like this this had to
be the result of some kind of
uh you know higher intelligence or
divinely inspired design
I would put it slightly more generally
than that I would say look we Face a
choice
either it's just chance that those
numbers are right for life or
we have the numbers right for life
because they are the right numbers for
life in other words that there's some
some other type some kind of goal direct
different number some kind of goal
directedness at the fundamental level so
and I you know I consider a lot of
different so some people would say oh
that's God
but I don't like that hypothesis
for a familiar reason you know I just
think it's it's really implausible that
a loving or powerful God
that could create anything would create
a universe
so full of suffering and
seemingly preventable evil and
so so tomorrow that's that's like the
sort of anthropomorphized God right yeah
the god in the the god defined as some
kind of
human-like yeah right intelligence that
has a moral compass and a and a code of
ethics and yeah you know marching orders
for me you know what what the world
should look like or the universe should
look like as opposed to some kind of
intelligence that
doesn't adhere to that limited structure
of of of
intelligence yeah absolutely so what I'm
rejecting is the very traditional
Western idea of goddess philosophers
call it the Omni God you know omnipotent
all omniscient
omnibenevolent I.E all-knowing
all-powerful perfectly good
so I I think this this data that
that view can't handle
suffering
evil but there's also data that the
traditional meaningless Universe picture
can't handle
right namely the fine-tuning and certain
other philosophical considerations
so but yeah as you say that's just that
maybe that the very
um traditional idea of God but I
consider a range of hypotheses in
between so
so basically I consider kind of three
three different options
firstly kind of non-standard designers
so you might have a bad designer an
indifferent designer
a limited designer
um or maybe the simulation hypothesis
maybe we're in a computer simulation and
our creator isn't any kind of god-like
being at all it's just some
some guy some scientist in the in the
next Universe up
um so so they're they're kind of close
to guarding that they're still designers
just a bit tweaked
um but it's not obvious to me actually
this is why I kind of qualified what you
said a bit it's not it's not I think the
fine tuning is evidence for goal
directedness but it's not actually
obvious to me you need a kind of mind
behind goal directedness
so
we're back to Thomas Nagel he had this
book in 2012
um mind and Cosmos where he defended the
idea of what he called teleological laws
so teleology just means the Greek for
purpose or goal so he had this idea of
laws of nature so not a not a personal
designer
just laws of nature with goals built
into them
so so you know the standard way we think
of laws of physics they kind of
work from past to future you know you
take what's happening now and that
determines what's going to happen at the
next moment and the next moment the next
moment but the but Nagel's teleological
laws
are aiming at some go sort of work from
future to past they're aiming at some
goal in the future
and impacting on the present moment to
to bring us closer to those goals so
maybe there's just a
a law of nature
that has to kind of fit in with the
standard laws of physics but which is in
some way inclining the universe towards
life
and the third hypothesis I consider
which fits with my earlier work on pan
psychism is Cosmo psychism right if
you've if you're already if you've
already got a conscious universe
then maybe this goal directedness is
just the goal directed us of the
conscious Universe maybe in some sense
the conscious universe fine-tuned itself
so you know right but it begs the
question of who designed the
Consciousness in the universe
there's always you know there's always
another Veil to step behind with this
yeah well
I mean every every Wittgenstein said
explanations have to end somewhere
everyone has to stop somewhere you know
the theater stops with guard The Atheist
stops with
the Big Bang or the laws of physics the
question is
is it an acceptable stopping point
to my mind stopping with the fine-tuning
is not an acceptable stopping point
because it's just at least in the
physics as we understand it now it's
just so wildly improbable
that we'd have the right numbers for
Life by chance so we can't stop there
but I think we could stop with
teleological laws I don't know or some
kind of non-standard design of course
other people start with the Multiverse
that's I've got other problems with that
hypothesis so I used to go for the
Multiverse myself but I've been
persuaded by
philosophers of probability that there's
some fallacious reasoning going on in
the that whole Multiverse section oh
that's interesting I mean that could be
a whole other podcast I mean because
when you get into
uh
I mean does not
an exploration of quantum physics bring
this up like it it conjures Dimensions
beyond the perceptible three dimensions
to which we experience reality right and
yeah and that means that there are
alternate realities occurring
theoretically right that the math can
prove value all right is that not the
case linking not to the Multiverse you
mean sure so yeah if that's the case is
that not an argument for the existence
of a or the Multiverse yeah there's a
great philosopher of physics at uh
Birmingham university called Al Wilson
who
who who takes the the Multiverse
in that direction and
so I mean standardly when when
physicists or philosophers try to
explain the fine-tuning in terms of a
Multiverse it's the inflationary
cosmology models where we have this
sort of vastly expanding mother Universe
Mega universe and then these
smaller bubble universes
slow down within it
and wear one of those but what is less
explored but which has been explored by
Al Wilson for example is is the um
taking the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics and trying to work on
that Multiverse to explain fine tuning
but you need to you need to at least
Tinker a bit because
so the the many worlds doesn't give you
every logical possibility it gives you
um every possibility consistent with the
laws of quantum mechanics
but as physics is right now the laws of
quantum mechanics are fine-tuned so
so you're going to have to somehow get
to possibilities that are
um
where the constants vary and so that
you're gonna that's that's
moving a little bit beyond just just the
many worlds interpretation
and you could try and justify that with
um
as you could try and justify that with
the need to explain the fine tuning but
this is where I think there's this
fallacious reasoning comes in should I
yeah go yeah please
uh
it is moving beyond my ability to
understand what's actually happening so
this well this this is one of the things
so I used to think the Multiverse was
the obvious explanation of fine-tuning
for a long time I feel kind of stupid I
feel silly defending this Cosmic purpose
stuff but
I was just persuaded by philosophers of
probability
that there's some very dodgy reasoning
going on here and you know I I just
really believe in that Enlightenment aim
of you know
trying to follow the the evidence of the
arguments where they go and this is this
is where it's taken me
um and this is what one of the things
I'm really excited about with this book
actually this is not my own idea it's
been in the philosophical literature for
decades
but it's a typical example of academics
talking to themselves nobody knows about
it outside of academic philosophy
despite huge interest in this
fine-tuning stuff you know from
physicists or
theologians or whatever
all right well I just I'll just run you
through the basic idea there's a huge
discussion here
but I've got an article in in Scientific
American making the basic case as well
so the the charge is that
this inference from fine-tuning to the
Multiverse
commits What's called the inverse
gambler's fallacy okay
so let me
let me try and give you give you an
analogy right so suppose you and I go to
a casino right and we walk in
um with the first the first thing we see
is this guy having an incredible run of
luck right he just keeps winning he's
rolling double sixes all the time so I
and then I say to you wow there must be
loads of people playing in the casino
tonight
and you say what what you mean what are
you we've just seen this one guy
and then I say well look
if there's just one person in the casino
then it's incredibly improbable that
someone would have such an incredible
run of luck
but if there's lots of people
playing in the casino tonight then it's
not so surprising that one of them's
gonna have an incredible Runner look now
I think you'd rightly say to me
that's a fallacy you know we've only
seen this one guy
and no matter that's our evidence this
one guy and no matter how many other
people there are playing in the casino
it has no bearing on whether this one
guy is gonna play well
and everyone agrees that's a fallacy so
that's the inverse gambler's fallacy
everyone agrees on that
but it looks like the Multiverse
reasoning is strikingly similar at least
in insofar as they're explaining fine
tuning so they say oh wow look you know
it's so improbable that
um physics is fine-tuned for life has
the right numbers for life we won the
cosmic Lottery
so there must be loads of other
universes where the numbers are already
crap hmm but it's the same fallacy
because all we've observed is this one
universe
and no matter how many other universes
there are out there it doesn't make it
any more likely that this this universe
the only one we've ever observed
has numbers fine-tuned for life so
there's all sorts of discussion and
responses and selection effect and
um but
you know I think I I'm just pretty
persuaded that this is just not an
option and so weird as it is
we have to try and make sense of
some kind of goal directedness at the
fundamental level of reality doesn't
need to be the traditional God but it's
gonna be
pretty different to how we normally
think of science yeah it's uh
I'm sort of resisting the temptation to
just continue to dig this hole deeper in
here I don't know where we're going to
end up with it but I feel like
you know that
those statements
um
uh
require you to Define life in a certain
way yeah we have this decimal number and
laws of physics and our understanding of
of what life is and a Confluence of
circumstances that have allowed us to
you know flourish essentially but
perhaps if that decimal number was
different and the role of the dice to
extend the gambler's metaphor was a
little bit different and the universe is
either expanding or Contracting at a
different rate that that would have
produced a form of life that is
something we have no understanding yeah
I say yeah right yeah
so is it just so yeah this is a you know
this is a
an important response to these arguments
are they relying on just
our kind of life or carbon-based life or
something some of the fine-tuning is to
do with carbon
although even even there you know it's
it's not carbon isn't just the stuff
we're made of
carbon is incredibly versatile as a
chemical element
um the number of things it can combine
with I can't remember the details
offhand and you you know you need to get
stars going and to to get carbon out of
them
um
but
I think a lot of the fine-tuning or at
least
some of the fine-tuning it's not just to
do with
carbon based life for our kind of life
it's to do with any kind of
structural complexity at all any kind of
chemistry at all so you know take the
cosmological constant example
either the universe
expands so quickly that no two particles
ever meet or everything collapsed back
on itself in a Split Second
it's you know it's that's not you're
just not going to get any kind of it
seems even without being able to pin
down exactly what life is I think we can
say in either of those possibilities
you're not gonna get
anything sure you could call life that
would be yeah I understand I understand
I I I think where my mind goes
is
is this idea of taking a step back and
having an honest sort of accounting of
the capacity of the human mind to
understand things right and I think we
we are pubridic as a species in terms of
what we think we can and can't do like I
think that we operate with this
sensibility that there's nothing beyond
our grasp in terms of understanding it's
just a matter of time before we figure
it all out but I think that that is
qualitatively incorrect like if you look
at
your pet or let's say you have a snake
you could that snake is never going to
understand the human language like it
just it doesn't have the neural capacity
to do that so why do we think that our
neural capacity is complete like we're
just missing a lobe or two that would
make so many of the questions that we
grapple with completely obvious yep but
it just eludes our ability to understand
because of our inherent physiological
limitations yeah
yeah I mean I've
I've got a lot of time for that for that
kind of position in fact
this is the the position
um
Rebecca Goldstein was defending in this
debate I was in last night I guess it's
what philosophers call the mysterian
position
um at least in the context of
Consciousness that
maybe this is just beyond us you know
dogs can't do mathematics they just
don't have the right brains maybe
solving Consciousness or fine-tuning is
is um is just beyond what humans are
able to do maybe some higher alien
species would would manage it more
easily but um
but
while we've got explanations that
as far as we can see
would do the job
then I think the rational thing to do is
to take those exclamation seriously I
think
the the thing with the the reason people
feel nervous with fine-tuning
is not because we can't think of an
explanation it's because the
explanations don't fit with how we've
got used to science I think it's the
same situation
as in the um 16th century when we first
started getting evidence that
the Earth wasn't in the center of the
universe
you know um
people couldn't handle it so they
postulated
little extra orbits of the planets
epicycles
um in addition to their basic orbits
around the earth so the idea of
everything crazy mental gymnastics yeah
and then that didn't work so it's
epicycles upon epicycles and you know of
course all of that was eventually Blown
Away by Copernicus a simple idea that
the Earth isn't in the center the sun's
in the center
um and we think now I think we think oh
they were so stupid you know stupid
religious people we're so enlightened
now but every generation absorbs a world
view that they can't think Beyond
and I you know you you start talking
about Cosmic goal directedness
with philosophers or scientists they're
going to start laughing at you as I'm
sure you know
people left only started saying you know
maybe the Earth is going around the Sun
I just think
there's always that
cultural baggage that it's hard to get
Beyond but I think we've just gotta
cling to that Enlightenment goal of
following the evidence where it lies and
sorry following the evidence where it
leads and to my mind you know
in our standard ways of thinking about
evidence
it's the fine-tuning
seems to be suggesting some kind of goal
directedness at the fundamental level
and we've just got it weird as that is
face up to it and and
I think we can formulate possible
explanations
they might be wrong we can never
guarantee that they're the right
explanations but while we can come up
with explanations we should take them
seriously yeah
assuming pan psychism to be true
consciousness
exists at the fundamental level of
matter and reality
what is your sense of what that tells us
about the nature of human consciousness
at death do you have a theory as to
where that goes or what happens to that
wow
it's a big question so
I mean again there are that there are no
obvious implications that I mean pan
psychism is structurally very similar to
materialism
and that's part of the reason I think
it's quite attractive that it in terms
of
the causal structure of reality in terms
of what stuff does
we say physics gets that right
it's just that that those structures are
filled out in some sense with
Consciousness and so
you know insofar as that
our best science tells us that you know
the matter making me up is gonna come
apart and cease to be then
it looks like materialism pants I guess
are going to be in the same boat I mean
except
and I very speculatively explore this in
the final chapter of my book
these more mystical suggestions that
experience meditators in in higher
States Of Consciousness somehow become
aware that
there is something at the core of each
conscious mind
that is
beyond all that change and it's in some
sense Timeless or unconditioned or
something like that
um
insofar as we take those ideas seriously
that might afford some kind of
impersonal non-individual
survival after death
um
I think maybe that's that's the best the
individual like the sense of of
individuation
in the sea of Consciousness gets
absorbed by the greater ocean of
Consciousness yeah and gets
recapitulated or somehow
uh uh you know assimilated into
the consciousness of everything
yeah and um
you know for people who
you think of Buddhists or
advice of adanta Hindus who
try to struggle to to get back to that
being absorbed into
unconditioned Consciousness or whatever
they try to get rid of the car the Bad
Karma
but if there's a if there's a past life
you know sort of reincarnation piece to
Allah yeah yeah yeah but suppose that's
not true the The Reincarnation bit and
the karma bit well maybe a death just
everyone gets enlightened because
you know the
outer layers peel off and you just
get absorbed into that unconditioned
Consciousness at the core
I just want to be clear I don't believe
this I I take the idea seriously on the
basis that
it's a fairly commonly reported
um
experience of people who've explored
Consciousness in a very deep way so I I
don't think I'd say you know
I'm confident that's true
but
I take it seriously and it you can do as
a pansychist I think if you if you're a
materialist you have to say that can't
be true it doesn't fit with my world
view but as a pan psychist it fits with
my world view I take the possibility
seriously
but I don't know I don't know I'm I'm
also open to life being pretty horrific
and tragic and so
who knows but that's what I'm saying you
know you can you don't have to
nobody knows what's going on you don't
have to we don't have to make decisions
to you know to engage with these
possibilities and to in one spiritual
practice and I like the idea of starting
with nobody knows what's going on like
nobody knows kind of really is true
right like how much do we really know
and the more you learn the more you
realize how little we actually know
about all of this stuff absolutely
absolutely
you know and
so listen so if you're asking me about
spirituality one thing that is important
that has become important to me
in recent years is
living in hope that that there is a
purpose to existence and thinking of
the thing the good I do is contributing
in some tiny way to some greater purpose
now I don't I don't know whether there
is ultimately a purpose I think you know
there are these suggestive
suggestive reasons to take the idea
seriously
but even if there is kind of cosmic
purpose maybe the purpose is done
already or maybe it's not a great
purpose or
but I think it's I think it's
reasonable to live in hope that there is
some greater purpose that's still
unfolding and
I find that idea motivates me and it
keeps my ego in check you know stops me
thinking about my own narrow
self-interests and it gives me a deep
sense of meaning and purpose and
if it turns out I was completely wrong
and it's all [__] you know I still
think I've
gained much and lost nothing from living
in Hope of
of a greater purpose to things so so
that's part of what I want to advocate
in this new book of that
that possible way of living
in that kind of hope and that there is
grounds to take to take to take that
possibility seriously even though
nobody knows what the hell's going on
right or something right I mean I do
like that idea you know to
presume the existence or the possibility
of pan psychism is to embrace
a qualitatively different but perhaps
more expansive sense of of what reality
is that makes you feel
like there is I don't know if an
intelligence or a purpose is the right
word but at least at a base level at a
minimum a connectivity amongst you know
our fellow organisms that
makes me makes gives me like I don't
know just gives me a uh
what's the right word
not necessarily purpose but
collectivism I suppose yeah
yeah
yeah I think there's
there's
I think there is a need for something
like that I mean there are so many
powerful forces in the modern world you
know
consumerism and global capitalism and
National sentiments and
I think there does need to use a little
collection to counterbalance that and
some
think we can we can build on for a more
hopeful picture of things I think the
idea that we can all just be rational
and enlightened and you know we can all
just
um
just through just through plain rational
thinking we can all learn to be nice and
respectful I think maybe that's not an
inspiring enough Vision to to motivate
people
um to counter these more more negative
influences in life I mean things are
things are pretty messed up in a lot of
ways at the moment I think we need to
maybe think of
a world view that I think in the absence
of a world view that gives
in which people can understand the
meaning and significance of their lives
I think people turn to other ways of
making sense of the meaning of their
lives
you know sort of nationalism or
consumerism and so on and so I think
there is this need to which is which has
always been part of what philosophy is
all about
building a world view a way of seeing
the world that makes sense of the
meaning and significance of your life so
I think that is
essential part of the human condition
yeah that's beautiful and and I think
just to kind of you know
end this or you know kind of land this
conversation
um I mean that seems like a beautiful
takeaway from your work and and and from
the book but if there's anything else
that you want people to really kind of
understand
um
about
how philosophy can operate in as a
positive animating force in our lives
like whether it's pan psychism or
otherwise we sort of think of
of philosophy as an academic Pursuit but
but honestly the it's they're operating
systems for living right they're meant
to be practiced
yeah yeah I mean I think in many ways
the religion of our times is scientism
you know the idea that the only things
you're allowed to believe in
are those that can be demonstrated on
the basis of observation experiments
now if you zealously clung to that as
we've discussed you wouldn't believe in
your own
conscious mind because that's not
something that can be can be known about
in that way you wouldn't believe in
value you wouldn't believe in
the kind of truths mathematicians come
up with which don't seem to concern the
physical world of space and time
so I think I mean my conception of
philosophy the task of philosophy is
synthesis
it's a matter of
taking all the things we know to be true
in different ways of course scientific
truth some experiments but also the
reality of our own consciousness
the reality perhaps of value and the
kind of mathematical truths that we know
about through mathematical intuition
taking all these things we know and
bringing them together synthesizing them
into a world view but that's that that's
the
the ancient Noble task of philosophy
that I think we've lost sight of and we
need to come back to and hopefully out
of that active synthesis
will emerge
a picture of reality that in which we
can find a place in which we can
live our meaning out in a way that's
rationally acceptable scientifically
plausible but also good for our mental
and spiritual health yeah
well I appreciate you coming to talk to
me today thanks a lot but I've seen
anything we didn't cover do we what else
do we what do we miss I think we've done
it all am I I think we covered a lot of
stuff
free well we didn't do Free Will um free
Will's a whole other I mean that's a
that's two hours in the other direction
we could do that next time let's let's
come back when the new book comes was
the new book gonna be called again
it's got the very uh humble title the
purpose of existence
between God and Atheism so yes very
finished at the end of this month I
don't remember that's coming up very
good but uh sometime next year is the
plan well in the meantime everybody go
check out Galileo's error it's uh it's
it's really it really has provoked me it
made me think deeply about things that
are counter-intuitive and has given me
kind of an expansive you know
perspective on not just Consciousness
but you know this sort of how to think
about life
you know and I think that does as an
operating system trickle down into
how we make decisions and you know how
we prioritize how we invest our time so
thank you for that and I think the work
you're doing is super fascinating and
you're uh always welcome to come back to
continue the conversation oh great
thanks a lot Rich I'm glad we finally
managed to have this conversation years
in the making it's been really glad to
have made it happen yeah and uh yeah I
mean we didn't we didn't I mean
we didn't solve all the world's problems
but maybe next time we can do that a few
left few loose ends to tie up all right
great thank you cheers
please
[Music]